blink once if you live blink twice if
you die or just stare straight ahead if
you're not going to tell me try not to
blink for as long as are you glad that
you can stop keeping these damn secrets
are you glad that we finally got reached
the end of the road you know have it out
there have everyone experiences epic
tale you know what I mean like people
are gonna be yearning for it it's such
an amazing amazing fan base and they
really have been just dying to see it
now they get to that's pretty cool um
you're a woman who lives in a world of
Secrets
same with the Walking Dead is there
anything you can tell us can you tell us
anything about Black Panther too because
apparently a lot of it hedges on this
movie we sharing in for me we are we
share information you know this is
called some sort of there's something
like symbiotic about this I don't know
and seeing all these folks and basically
for the last time it still got to be
bittersweet but fun folks you know
things happen all the time on my show
but we remain family Carl azuz lizard
I'm exactly God you keep secrets well
[Music]